et pour en parler nous sommes avec marie
george buffet députée pcf de
seine-saint-denis également on en
parlera avec vous ma légende me fait
évidemment au rapporteur d'un rapport
sur les effets de la crise du coc vide
sur l'enfance et la jeunesse bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous yves blein député
la raim de la 14e circonscription du
rhône bonsoir à vous également enfin
christophe prudhomme porte parole de
l'association des médecins urgentistes
en france bonsoir et merci à tous les
trois mètres avec nous en direct sur
arte france alors avant de vous faire
réagir sur cette longue conférence de
presse et les nouvelles annonces vous
propose d'écouter le premier ministre
qui défendent sa stratégie globale face
au co vide
les résultats de notre stratégie nous
place aujourd'hui dans une situation
comparative plus qu'honorable en europe
tant au niveau des taux d'incidence que
des taux de positivité des tests alors
marie george buffet le premier ministre
qui comptera pas qu'un parce qu'il avait
subi beaucoup de critiques ces derniers
temps mais il est plutôt satisfait de sa
stratégie de la stratégie de son
gouvernement la france fait en gros
mieux que nos voisins européens
je ne pense pas que l'époque soit ce pop
art et avec d'autres pays
l'important c'est d'être capable de
répondre à cette prise à cette pandémie
et de protéger les hommes et les femmes
qui vivent sur ce territoire
je suis particulièrement déçu des
annonces concernant le monde étudiant
franchement annoncé qu'il va y avoir une
rue d'une réunion de la conférence des
présidents d'université qui doit y avoir
une concertation était syndicat étudiant
pour envisager la reprise progressive
découvrant faculté on a l'impression que
tout cela a pris un temps infini celle
aurait dû déjà être pensée est réglée
avant les vacances de fin d'année les
étudiants sont amenés à donner et à 10
le monde de précarité sociale de rupture
de la continuité pédagogique
on a l'impression que le gouvernement ne
prend pas la même la paix de mesure de
ce désarroi alors vous avez un petit peu
de vent c'est effectivement ces annonces
alors on va en parler de ces universités
c'était quelque chose de très attendu un
débat était consacré d'ailleurs aux
universités hier à l'assemblée nationale
qui vous concerne effectivement
particulièrement avec votre rapport je
voudrais d'abord qu'on revienne sur les
grosses annonces qui pour le coup
implique toute la france qui concerne
tous les français un couvre-feu à 18
heures qui sera mis en place à partir de
samedi pour au moins 15 jours sur
l'ensemble dû territoire métropolitain
français
votre réaction christian prudhomme on
n'a pas choisi le confinement strict
mais on a choisi ce couvre-feu de 18h
plutôt satisfaisant ça va payer
écoutez je ne sais pas si ça va payer ce
qu'ils payent c'est une stratégie
globale vous savez ce la risée sur
confinement couvre-feu n'est pas la
bonne solution vous savez le virus à sa
propre vie je ne suis pas sûr que ce
soit le couvre-feu avancé à 18 heures
qui est fait que dans un certain nombre
de départements
l'incidence du nombre de cas positifs
diminue ce qui est clair c'est que nous
avons une arme qui est efficace si on le
voit dans un grand nombre de pays c'est
le dépistage avec l' isolement des
personnes contagieuses
or nous sommes toujours sur une mauvaise
pente concernant ce dépistage parce
qu'on isole pas assez on dépiste le
beaucoup mais on isole pas voilà donc il
suffit pas de se targuer de faire
beaucoup de tests quand il ne fonctionne
pas il faut savoir que le gouvernement
n'a pris une mesure qui est très
efficace pour les salariés qui est de
supprimer le jour de carence que il ya
dix jours ce jour de carence est bien
faisait qu'un certain nombre de
personnes continuaient à aller
travailler
en attendant d'avoir le résultat de
leurs tests or la règle
au moindre doute c'est de ne plus aller
travailler physiquement
quand on ajoute des cons et qu'on fait
le test
or un certain nombre de salariés pour ne
pas de perdre donc ce jour de carence
continuer à aller travailler en
attendant le résultat du test
et puis vous savez sur le vaccin ya
quand même des ratés au démarrage et moi
je n'ai pas compris pourquoi les
départements les plus touchés n'ont pas
été priorisés pour pouvoir disposer très
rapidement d'une vaccination de masse
dans ces départements
voyez donc la mettre sur le même plan
des départements où il ya besoin de
renforcer les mesures et puis d'autre
pour l'instant
eh bien on pourrait être donc avec des
mesures plus légère ça ne paraît pas
cohérent vous savez le virus n'a pas de
frontières et donc ce sont des régions
qui sont touchés plus que des pays or
depuis le début il ya eu qu une
coordination en europe chacun fait dans
son coin des meules et prend des mesures
de confinement le couvre feu etc
il serait bien que l'on puisse adapter
ces mesures en fonction de l'urgence
dans les régions les plus contaminés
voilà donc aujourd'hui
simplement on a attendu trois jours ça
et ce qui est assez énervant dans cette
épidémie
c'est que il faut attendre l'oracle
alors cette fois ci c'était le premier
ministre et on voit bien que il ya des
difficultés parce qu'on attend que le
premier ministre nous explique qu'il va
y avoir un numéro vert que finalement le
site dédié de santé publique ne
fonctionne pas bien et saturé etc
il serait bien que plutôt que d'attendre
l'oracle eh bien on met au travail
les services de l'état pour que et les
services en lien avec les collectivités
locales pour qu'on puisse avoir
effectivement des tests et un isolement
qui fonctionne et une vaccination qui
fonctionne et vous savez sur la
vaccination
eh bien il serait bien qu'on fasse
confiance au terrain et qu'on vaccine
dans les quartiers avec les médecins
avec les pharmaciens avec les
infirmières parce que c'est là qu'est
fectivement permettra de vacciner en
masse parce que les gens retrouveront la
confiance ces personnes qui connaissent
et donc jusqu'à présent c'est pas la
stratégie qui a été adoptée on va mettre
en place des seins de maxis le christ a
prudemment on va y revenir sur ses
vaccins va prendre les thèmes dans
l'ordre en attendant pour le moment pas
de troisième confinement le premier
ministre se lève cette possibilité en
cas de dégradation de la situation alors
qu'en penser français des nouvelles
restrictions à ce couvre-feu à 18h
étendue à tout le territoire je vous
propose d'écouter ces quelques parisiens
interrogés dans la passe quand en
province est un peu plus simple qu'en
région parisienne de ski à les
contraintes du métro les horaires sont
différents la circulation les bouchons
donc là apprécié au néo retraités mais
c'est pas contraignant mais pour des
actifs je pense que oui encore plus de
gens qui vont se retrouver aux mêmes
heures dans l'est dans les commerces moi
donc ça va multiplier encore plus moi je
trouve ça un multi bien encore puisqu'il
sera pas autant mieux faire au
confinement total parce que ça ne sert à
rien à 20 heures c'est déjà dur à 18
heures ça sera encore plus dure autant
mieux il nous raconte film totalement on
restera quelques jours on avance dans le
temps et en fin de compte
malheureusement on fait des concessions
et ça s'arrange jamais encontre ailleurs
on avance toujours le pire en pire
le couvre-feu de 18h c'est une bêtise
voilà parce qu'on était à 20h et
maintenant ils ne font pas ça 18h05
scénario se sert à rien du tout voilà
c'est france est un petit peu mitigés
notamment sur la notion de couvre-feu à
18 heures certains auraient aimé à la
limite qu'on y aille franchement qui
tarde à régler les choses
il se plaint vous vous êtes plutôt
satisfait alors je ne vais pas parler de
demi mesure serait un jugement de valeur
de ma part mais en tout cas voilà on ne
confirme pas mais on avance ce couvre
feu à toute la hâte au lp oui je ne sais
pas s'il faut parler de satisfaction à
vrai dire je pense que la tactique si on
peut dire comme cela qui est adopté par
le gouvernement les jours qu'elle
pourrait en être une autre c'est de
toute façon de s'adapter à l'évolution
de la situation et de s'adapter au plus
près de l'évolution de la situation ce
que l'on constate aujourd'hui c'est que
clairement la pandémie et est reparti et
l'état un niveau important moindre que
dans d'autres pays ce qui permet
effectivement d'être dans des mesures
moins contraignante on n'est pas dans un
confinement total mais on cherche
néanmoins à éviter le plus possible le
brassage de la population à des horaires
ou c'est pas absolument indispensable
parce qu'on doit aller au travail parce
qu'on doit aller à l'école c'est ce qui
est recherché tout en laissant la
possibilité au commerce de rester ouvert
puisque il faut bien que les personnes
les français puissent s'alimenter et
puis faire leurs courses etc
mais en le faisant dans des volumes
horaires qu'ils fassent qu'on limite
encore une folle le brassage de la
population
quand on sait que si on a constaté à
l'occasion des fêtes que c'est un des
vecteurs de propagation du virus donc
satisfait je dirais qu'il ya pas lieu de
se satisfaire d'une réponse
voilà adapter la situation d'aujourd'hui
en tout cas il y avait un autre sujet
qui était sur toutes les lèvres le cas
des écoles puisqu'on sait depuis peu que
de plus en plus les enfants sont
atteints par ce qu vie d'un 10 % pour
les moins de 10 ans selon une étude
récente de santé publique france
pourtant le gouvernement a décidé de ne
pas les fermer en c'était l'un des
objectifs de jean michel blanquer
néanmoins il aura un protocole plus
strictes à la cantine je vous propose
d'écouter tout d'abord le ministre de
l'éducation
bonjour dès la semaine du 25 janvier les
travaux dirigés pourront donc reprendre
en demi-groupe pour les étudiants de
première année c'est une étape sur ce
chemin avant de pouvoir réintégrer
davantage d'étudiants les protocoles
d'accueil devront prévenir le brassage
des étudiants garantir les règles de
distanciation
ils devront éviter que les étudiants
restent sur 6
pour les pauses méridiennes en lien avec
les équipes du ministère des solidarités
la santé dépistage individuel ou
collectif seront déployés des tests
antigénique seront mis à la disposition
des services de santé universitaire
notre stratégie de test prend un nouveau
tour avec dès le mois de janvier dans
les écoles les collèges et les lycées
une possibilité massif de déploiement
pour plus d'un million de personnels et
d'élèves pour accentuer notre
surveillance de la circulation du virus
en milieu scolaire et en complément de
ce que nous faisons déjà c'est-à-dire le
traçage des cas contacts ce qu'on
appelle parfois le contact racing va
évidemment continuer donc nous le
mettons en place avec chaque agence
régionale de santé depuis la rentrée
comme vous le montre le graphique que
vous voyez à l'écran et maintenant nous
aurons non seulement ce traçage donc qui
continuera mais aussi la possibilité
pour certains établissements d'avoir la
venue d'une équipe de dépistage de tous
les personnels et de tous les élèves sur
place chaque fois qu'il y aura trois cas
de contamination et puis il y aura aussi
l'identification de tous les personnels
lycéens et collégiens qui se verront
donc proposer un test dans les 48 heures
dans ce type d' hypothèse on attendu
donc le ministre de l'éducation et ait
auparavant la ministre de l'enseignement
on reparlera des universités dans un
second temps marie george buffet c'est
une bonne chose on laisse les écoles
ouvertes vous justement je le disais qui
est rapporteur des conséquences
notamment sur la souffrance des enfants
et des jeunes
sur les effets de la crise du coc vite
c'est quand même une bonne chose parce
que c'est vrai qu'on entendait les
pédiatres nous dire il faut que les
enfants restent à l'école il faut être
seulement maintenir les écoles ouvertes
des écoles les collèges les lycées
pourquoi parce que le confinement à des
montres et trois conséquences
extrêmement importantes d'abord une
conséquence physique avec une prise de
poids
l'absence de mobilité la réactivité ont
diminué chez les enfants selon les
pédiatres des conséquences ou psychique
parce que c'est pas facile pour un
enfant de perdre ce sujet de sociabilité
qu'il trouve à l'épaule d'abord avec les
professeurs mais aussi avec ses copains
et copines
il sort de chez lui il va vers un autre
monde pratiquer des activités physiques
ces terrains et puis conséquence au
christ sur la continuité pédagogique
parce que selon que les parents et des
routes il y ait au point de vue
numérique pas simplement les instruments
mais la connaissance du mérite d'avoir
conservé ou selon que des parents
étaient démunis par rapport à cela
les enfants n'ont pas pu avoir la même
continuité pédagogique et je vais
jusqu'à aux enfants les plus en
difficulté jauger
j'ai rencontré les familles et vous
placez en hôtels dans les hôtels sociaux
parfois il n'y a pas de wifi il n'y a
plus rien aux hypothèses questions et
les enfants étaient en rupture vraiment
au niveau pédagogique quid donc il faut
vraiment maintenir les écoles on trouve
en effet des parades par rapport à la
cantine des rails faut peut-être élargir
la coupure du midi multiplier les
services
il faut qu'on trouve des solutions mais
il faut que l'école reste ouverte et
c'est pour cela aussi je pense du tout
les university réouvre très vite le
médecin vous êtes christian prudhomme et
est d'accord avec ce postulat on sait
que beaucoup de pays de nombreux pays
européens ont fermé leur école c'est le
cas des ailes
des anglais également parce que je le
disais tout à l'heure le virus circule
davantage surtout avec ces nouvelles
souches très contagieuse c'était une
bonne chose et comme le dit marie-george
buffet de trouver la parade avec des
tests et plus de réflexion notamment
dans les cantines écoutez il faut
regarder les chiffres
la mortalité chez les moins de 25 ans
est quasiment nul voila ea et même
jusqu'à 45 ans nous avons les chiffres
sur l'ensemble de l'année 2020 la
mortalité en france des moins de 45 ans
a diminué alors oui les jeunes peuvent
être vecteurs du virus
encore que les études montrent que
beaucoup d'enfants sont contaminés par
leurs parents donc il faut maintenir ces
écoles et jusqu'aux universités ouvertes
très largement en prenant des mesures
parce que les conséquences et la santé a
trois composantes physiques
psychologiques et sociales
or là y'a rien au niveau physique dans
cette population là ils n'ont pas de
conséquence par contre au niveau
psychologique et social c'est une
catastrophe
moi je peux vous dire je travaille au
samu de seine-saint-denis nous avons
régulièrement des étudiants au téléphone
qui présente des dépressions graves qui
sont au bout du rouleau et au niveau
social
je discutais récemment avec un étudiant
qui faisaient le chauffeur hubert pour
pouvoir survivre et qui cherchaient
désespérément un stage parce que vous
savez pour certaines informations il
faut des stages et il avait un diplôme
qui pourraient être utiles dans la
période on our science
il demandait un stage comme attachés de
recherche clinique
il a eu un rendez-vous à l'assistance
publique on ne l'a même pas octroyer ce
stage
voyez donc il ya un véritable problème
je pense que on se trompe complètement
vis-à-vis des jeunes il faut privilégier
aujourd'hui chez ces jeunes le maintien
le autant que possible d'une vie normale
d'une vie sociale et et conséquences au
niveau psychologique le plus normale
possible
c'est très important aujourd'hui d'être
particulièrement vigilants ces instants
les conséquences vont être
catastrophiques au niveau de la santé
dans les mois et dans les années qui
viennent pour cette tranche de
population en tout cas
le gouvernement a autorisé la reprise
par demi groupe du travail dans les
universités ça ne vient pas un peu tard
yves blein cette voie là cette
autorisation parce que
les étudiants paient on viens de
l'entendre un lourd tribut il ya eu
quand même deux tentatives de suicide
cette semaine à lyon est-ce que c'est
pas un peu trop tard vous habitiez
d'abord dû à avoir un point de vue sur
la question de l'école peut-être avant
celui de l'université je crois
effectivement que l'école est le dernier
lieu à fermer marie george buffet
indiqué des problèmes de santé physique
de santé psychologique mais aussi la
question du décrochage scolaire qui est
vraiment une question importante là la
qualité de la sociologie de la vie à
l'école pour les enfants contre elle je
crois que effectivement
et puis y compris d'ailleurs pour la vie
en famille on a vu dans la première
personne où période de confinement des
tensions que le fait de garder les
enfants à la maison h 24 ans comme on y
peut aussi provoquer dans les familles
notamment dans les milieux modestes
celles qui ont des petits appartements
et qui vivent pas toujours dans les
meilleures conditions
ce qui fait qu effectivement c'est sans
aucun doute une meilleure qui était
absolument primordiale la question des
universités la ministre l'a indiqué le
25 janvier pourront reprendre les
travaux dirigés en présentiel en petit
groupe
on est très prudent sur la question
effectivement de la reprise à
l'université que les jeunes sont des
jeunes adultes qui commence à être
concernés par cette terrible épidémie et
qu' il faut à l'instar de ce que l'on
fait pour l'ensemble de la population
agir avec la plus grande prudence pour
éviter que cette contamination se
répondent
merci en tout cas tous les trois on
arrive malheureusement déjà là à l'issue
de ce débat à noter que le premier
ministre a aussi affirmé que la
vaccination concerne est la priorité des
priorités pour sortir de cette crise et
annoncé plus de 700 centres de
vaccination ouverts dès lundi mais ce
sera l'objet certainement d'un nouveau
débat merci à tous les trois d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france